الاثر الذي كان ناتجا عن هذه العمليه
عمليه الاغتيال ربما نستعرض الاثار من
امام مستشفى الشفاء في غزه مراسله الجزيره
هبه عكيله اهلا بك معنا ربما عدد الشهداء
هذه المره من العوائل بشكل كبير وان كان
هدف العمليه العسكريه كما تقول اسرائيل هم
قاده في سرايا
القدس اذا ما الذي رصدته لنا في هذا
الاطار بعد عمليه التشييع ماذا قال
الاطباء عن الشهداء وكيف كانت حالتهم عند
استلامهم
وطبيعه ايضا الاصابات المعلن عنها
نعم نحن هنا في مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه
غزه وهي المستشفيات في قطاع غزه من هذا
المستشفى خرجت معظم جسامين الشهداء الذين
استهدفهم القصف الاسرائيلي في عمليه
اغتيال متزامنه في ثلاثه اماكن في قطاع
غزه
في رفح وفي مدينه غزه تم استهداف ثلاثه من
قاده سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي ولكن الشهداء ايضا كانوا
من ذميهم من زوجاتهم واطفالهم وايضا من
جيران في نفس الابنيه السكنيه وبالتالي
كما اكدت وزاره الصحه ان عدد الشهداء كان
13 شهيدا منهم اربع
اربعه نساء واربع اطفال وايضا هناك 20
اصابه معظم الشهداء وصلوا بحاله الاشلاء
وفي صور قاسيه جدا حتى ان معظم الصور كان
يصعب عرضها على شاشات التلفزه او حتى
نقلها عبر الصور وايضا كان هناك اصابات
بين العشرين اصابه هناك على الاقل ثلاث
اصابات ما زالت حالاتهم الطبيه حسب
الاطباء هنا بين حرجه وخطيره وايضا عدد من
الاصابات متوسطه او اكثر من متوسطه
وبالتالي حاله الغضب في الشارع الفلسطيني
هنا كانت حاله كبيره من الغضب من
الاستهجان من الاستنكار لاقدام اسرائيل
على هذه العمليه عمليه الاغتيال بهذه
الصوره المباغته وخاصه وان الاوضاع خلال
القليله الماضيه كان هناك هدوءا نسبيا لم
يكن هناك تصعيدا وان مباغته اسرائيل بهذه
العمليه هي كانت
والاصعب خاصه وان الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه
كانت قبل سنوات ولم تقوم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم يقم بعمليات الاغتيال وان
كان قد لوح في الفتره الماضيه بان سياسه
الاغتيالات قد تعود وقد ينتهجها الجيش
الاسرائيلي ولكن كانت هذه الاقوال بين
معارضه اسرائيليه وتاييد اسرائيلي وخاصه
ونحن في عهد حكومه اسرائيليه يمينيه
متطرفه ايضا كان رد الفصائل الفلسطينيه
منذ عمليه الاغتيال بسياسه مختلفه
وباستراتيجيه مختلفه تماما لم تكن هناك
ردود واضحه عن كيفيه الرد زمان الرد وعن
طبيعه هذا الرد تحدثت معظم الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وخاصه الاجنحه العسكريه في
بيانات منفصله عن ان المقاومه لها حق الرد
وبان الثمن
سيكون ستدفعه سيدفعه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
برد المقاومه خاصه في بيان الغرفه
المشتركه للفصائل الفلسطينيه ولكن ما يزيد
التوتر حتى الان هو عدم تحديد المقاومه
لطبيعه هذا الرد وساعه الصفر او البدء في
المقاومه هل ستكون فقط في المنطقه نعم هل
سنقول في المنطقه المحيطه ام سيتوسع الى
مدن
لمتابعه تطور